circuit을 통해 gate를 적절히
평가하면, 이 와이어의 최종 값이 1이라는 것을 알 수 있어요.
그래서 전체 circuit은 그림이 보여주는 대로
구성된 일련의 연산을 설명하고, 결국
두 비트에서 한 비트로의 함수를 얻게 돼요.
이 특정 경우에요. 하지만 일반적으로는 임의의 수의
입력 및 출력 비트가 있을 수 있어요.
이 특정 circuit은 두 입력 비트의 배타적 OR을 계산해요. 그래서 출력이 1이 되려면
정확히
두 입력 비트 중 하나가 1이고 다른 하나가 0이어야 해요. 하지만 그건 별로
중요하지 않아요, 그냥 예시일 뿐이에요.
불리언 circuit에 대한 기본적인 사실은 임의의 수의 비트에서 임의의 수의 비트로의 어떤 함수든 계산할 수 있다는 거예요.
어떤 불리언 circuit으로든요. 다만 때때로
관심 있는 함수를 계산하려면
매우 큰 circuit이 필요할 수도 있어요.
circuit을 설명하는 데 사용되는
다른 스타일들도 있어요.
예를 들어, 이 그림은
이전에 봤던 것과 정확히 같은 circuit을 아마도 더 전형적인 스타일로 나타낸 거예요.
전기공학에서 다른 gate를 나타내는 모양에 대한 규약이 있는 스타일이에요.
우리는 이 특정 스타일을
사용하지 않을 거지만, Hadamard gate,
Controlled NOT gate 같은
Toffoli gate 등에 대한
우리만의 기호를 도입할 거예요.
여담으로, 여기서 circuit이라는
용어의 기원을 볼 수 있어요.
전기공학의 맥락에서는 전기가
circuit을 통해 순환하는 것을 생각하는 게 매우 자연스러워요.
하지만 이 시리즈에서는 전기가
circuit을 통해 이동하는 것이 아니라 정보가
circuit을 통해 이동하는 것을 이야기하고 있어요.
그리고 다시 한번, 우리에게 이것들은 항상 비순환적이고, 정보는
왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 이동해요.
여기 산술 circuit이라고 불리는
다른 유형의 circuit의 다른 예가 있어요.
이번에는 와이어가 숫자를 저장하고 gate는
덧셈과 곱셈 같은 산술 연산을 나타내요.
여기 산술 circuit의
예를 볼 수 있어요.
이 수업을 위해 이것이 무엇을 하는지는
중요하지 않아요. 그냥 다양한 종류의 circuit
개념이 있다는 것을 전달하기 위한 예시일 뿐이에요.
무작위성을 포함하는 circuit도
생각할 수 있어요. 예를 들어 gate가
확률적 연산을 나타내는 경우인데,
원한다면 하루 종일 앉아서 circuit 개념에 기반한 새로운 계산 모델을 꿈꿀 수도 있을 거예요.
quantum circuit 모델에서는
와이어가 qubit을 나타내고, gate는 유니터리 연산과 측정 모두를 나타내요.
여기 quantum circuit의
매우 간단한 예가 있어요.
이 circuit에는 qubit이 하나만 있는데,
수평선으로 표현되고, 사각형으로
표시된 gate는
이 qubit에 수행되는 유니터리 연산을 나타내요.
이 특정 예에는
측정이 없어요.
qubit에 X 같은 이름을 주고 싶으면,
다이어그램에서 여기에 X를 넣어서 표시할 수 있어요. 이건 선택사항이에요.
조금 전의 불리언 circuit에서처럼, 이 circuit을
시간이 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 흐르는
일련의 연산으로 생각할 수 있어요.
X로 시작해서 첫 번째 gate인
Hadamard gate를 적용하고
그다음 S gate를 적용해요.
그다음 또 다른 Hadamard
gate, 그리고 마지막으로 T gate예요.
이 연산들은 수업 1의
마지막 부분에서 봤고, 여기서 행렬
설명을 볼 수 있어요.
이 네 가지 연산을 순서대로
수행하면, 즉 먼저 H, 그다음
S, 그다음 다시 H, 그리고 T를 수행하면,
결합된 연산은 여기 이 곱으로
주어지는데, 순서가 본질적으로
뒤집힌다는 것을 기억하세요.
수업 1에서 이야기한 것처럼요. 행렬 곱셈을 수행하면 여기 이 행렬을 얻어요.
그래서 circuit이 qubit X에
미치는 작용은 이 유니터리 행렬로 설명돼요.
때때로 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서
어떤 입력을 넣는지 명시적으로 표시하고 싶을 때가 있는데, 여기 보이는 것처럼 할 수 있어요.
이 경우에는 circuit에
Ket 0을 입력하고 있어요.
그건 꽤 일반적이에요. Ket 0을 qubit의
초기화된 상태로 사용하는 경우가 많지만, 꼭 그래야 하는 건 아니에요.
다른 상태에 circuit을
적용하는 것도 고려할 수 있어요.
원한다면 이렇게 얻게 되는
출력 상태도 표시할 수 있어요.
여기 또 다른 예가 있는데, 이번에는
다이어그램에서 볼 수 있듯이
X와 Y라는 두 개의 qubit이 있어요.
여기 Hadamard gate가 있는데, qubit Y에 적용되고, 그다음에 여기 이 기호로
표시된 gate가 있어요.
이것은 Controlled NOT gate예요. 이전 수업에서
Controlled NOT 연산에 대해 이야기했어요.
여기 이 다이어그램에서 제어 qubit은
Y인데, 작은 채워진 원으로 표시되어 있고,
대상 qubit은 X인데, 플러스 기호처럼 보이는 것이 있는 큰 원으로 표시되어 있어요.
배타적 OR의 기호처럼
보여서 의미가 통해요.